applications that help us reduce the
repetitive tasks make us more productive
but building them is hard since it
stitches a lot of different applications
together
to explore one such application i've
invited david ting senior vice president
of engineering at knights a company
that's revolutionizing the workflow
automation by connecting data from
multiple applications compiling those
insights and then creating an end-to-end
automation workflow hi david welcome to
the show hi priyanka thank you for
having me
i am so excited to have you on the show
uh tell us a little bit about you and
nylis
i am the svp of engineering and i'm
responsible for nihilist product and
technical execution
natalie's mission is to make the world
more productive and we built up a very
scalable and secure platform to hand
commute handle communication data
driving business process automation okay
so how does it matter to me you as end
users if there are enough developers to
write all the applications you need to
automate and streamlined workflow the
world be much different today why would
i have to enter receive for expenses why
is it so hard to juggle my calendar when
i just need two hours of focus time
building applications to reduce
repetitive tasks are really hard and
nice mission is to make it easier for
you to build high ri application make
you a star in your work wow productivity
sounds really cool and yes i do not want
to get my to upload my receipts into a
system it should just happen
automatically
how does this actually work
so we capture real-time data from
service providers such as gmail
microsoft imap
we have data pipelines power ml models
behind the scene to create intelligent
data objects data from these insights
trigger programmable workflows and the
challenge is building up a distributed
real-time architecture for billions of
messages that we receive each day and
keep the end-to-end latency low and
predictable
all right so now that we have put the
customer expectation in perspective and
now that we know how nihilis gathers the
data and creates these insights
what were the technical drivers for
working with google cloud we came to
google with what we viewed as a very
challenging mission we have a large
enterprise customer in the financial
services space with very strict security
requirements pii can not be stored
persistently and the lifetime of each
server needs to be short to avoid
potential in-memory hacks this was a
great reason for us to rethink the
analysis architecture
the legacy nylon architecture is built
with python flasks on top of aws was
difficult and very costly to scale and
the end to end performance is unreliable
interesting why was it so costly to
scale
nyls processes over 20 terabytes of data
every day and the high volume of read
and writes are mainly hitting against
hundreds of my sequel shards the
workload is partitioned as email
accounts across a farm with a static
assignment because volume of the emails
is unpredictable for each account there
are many hot spots that emerge
throughout the day and causing high
variability and latency and some
insevere cases reliability issues
in order to address this we have to over
provision the system by good margin in
order to keep the latency in control
based on extensive load testing with the
same traffic load whenever we double the
infrastructure footprint we can lower
the p90 latency in half and at our
current scale doubling our footprint
is really means like a million dollar in
cloud cost uh so that's not a
sustainable strategy wow that is a lot
of money
all right so three big major issues that
you set out to solve the security
scalability performance and obviously
cost
so why did you pick google cloud
in my mind google cloud has the best
distributed technology has been a true
engineering partner throughout the
journey
the security scalability and stability
of the platform is second to none gke is
currently the best option out of any
cloud provider to run kubernetes
workload securely at scale and one of
the most performant data stores in
spanner so now i want to get into my
favorite part which is the architecture
how did you approach it what was it like
and how is it going we're able to
transition to a brand new architecture
and achieve a huge roi for the project
the big bets of using gke to handle the
container orchestration pumps up for
message bus and spanner for relational
data store has paid off handsomely we
went live on june 4th
and we really knocked it out of the park
everything has been scaling effectively
for example one application has
performed over
1 billion transaction in less than a
month and then this is on top of spanner
and what i cannot believe is is that uh
the latency is actually controlled very
well to seven cells millisecond and this
really speaks volumes to robustness of
gcp services
by working closely with the gcp account
team
and the great partner in redspin were
able to address most of the issues
before the launch so our customers qa
team went in and tested our initial
prototype they found zero issue
and we spent the rest of the time
optimizing the workload as we scale on
gcp great well how did you go from you
mentioned that you went from python
based application to go you did an
entire rewrite
how did you do that and
um moving from virtual machine instances
on ec2 to gke how did that process
happen
as part of the reimagine imagination
exercise we have to take some big bets
and what we did was we actually decided
to rewrite our services and go
because we believe that there's a 10x
throughput improvement when we when we
do this the second part is moving
basically the orchestration tier
from cloud specific and um
and kind of like an ews auto scaler
group we basically want to go with the
industry standard in gke or kubernetes
so we use gke to orchestrate the
containers and due to the security
requirements the nodes have to be cycled
very quickly so we're able to take
advantage of the fact that we can have
up to 15 000 nodes in the kubernetes
cluster on gke and that's actually
something that other cloud providers
don't provide in addition we're also
using gvisor to run the containers to
create a strong isolation between the
application and operating system this
helps us to lock down the host memory
and storage access and enforce lease
permission principle at the operating
system level earlier you mentioned 20
plus terabytes of data being processed
in hundreds of my sequel shards which
obviously wasn't really efficient and
was also extremely costly
how did you solve that as you reimagined
this architecture in google cloud we
made some big bets and so we used
spanner as the relational data store to
keep states for the application and also
store the keys
for each one of the accounts we need to
connect to
so faster
read and write access performance
extremely critical for a large number of
calls
we need the consistent high performance
they have predictable end-to-end latency
and and that bet actually has paid off
by betting on running on gcp services
versus doing it ourselves
lastly nyls does not have the whole pii
so this information is pushed so that
once
our customers receive it we purge the
information from our store
for security reasons for communication
between those micro services
you used pumps up can we talk a little
bit about
why and how pops up has been helpful
yes so we went from a very
database-centric design to event-centric
design so for us the message bus is a
key in the heart of our
whole design so we chose google pub sub
for event driven microservices
architecture
and just as a comparison in the aws
world in the legacy architecture because
it's actually more of a data-driven
architecture
the uh the data is written into dynamo
then it gets converted to by atlanta
function and then it goes to kinesis
event stream
so in google cloud we want to simplify
this so we want event first and then so
we re wrote it directly on google pub
sub so it actually puts a lot of string
on the system so there's a lot of trust
that we have in how the scales and how
it's going to perform
reliably and uh consistently and we're
very happy with the experience on google
pubs where the performance latency is
minimal even when we have to burst to
tens of thousands of right per second
so we even can even think about eventbus
uh to basically be like a data store for
us because it is that reliable and
scalable for us
yeah that is amazing to hear what are
the
what are some of the benefits that
you've achieved after migrating to
google cloud
this could not happen without
exceptional service so we're very happy
with everyone we worked with
at gcp
we're able to get over 30 times the
throughput per node after the rewriting
go and in addition the elasticity of the
architecture has been amazing it's
reliable latency doesn't go down
performance is actually stable as we
actually has traffic spike it's just
outright amazing when you work with the
high scale architecture
our customer has been migrating their
entire user base onto annihilus in june
and the process has been extremely
smooth and in addition during amazon
prime day where there's a lot of
burst in e-commerce transaction come in
within a minute we saw the number of
nodes went from like a handful to tens
of thousands of nodes like within a few
minutes
and we're able to handle the peak
consistently and the p90 performance
actually was stable even on with those
spikes and it's just really amazing to
think back and we're able to accomplish
out all of that in just three months wow
three months is a pretty impressive
timeline for a migration this big where
you had to rewrite from
from
one language to another in this case
python to go and then um and then also
learning all these new tools
gk spanner and
npub sub and i'm sure it was a very
massive team effort what was your
experience like working with the google
team and the partner in this process
i want to first thank the nihilus
engineering team i have not worked with
a group that is talented and is
dedicated in their work in my career
secondly i would like to thank our
partner gcp investment for making this
happen
we're able to work as one team over
emails and slack and resolve issues in
real time
most companies need at least one year to
pull off an architectural overhaul of
disorder and magnitude
this is absolutely phenomenal the speed
the collaboration
what is the road ahead what does future
technical enhancement look like for your
architecture
with the success we experienced we want
to shoot bigger
so
we have the confidence to handle more
challenges ahead and we're looking to
work with uh gcp on advanced ai ml use
cases where we're extracting valuable
insight contained within communication
channels automating workflows for our
clients
our customers has planned to increase
their usage several orders of magnitude
and they're pushing with all their
marketing power to reach more users and
customers and of course we have many
more mega clients waiting in our
pipeline and we have the confidence with
the partnership that we have to
basically
take out more of them concurrently well
all that sounds really exciting and i
wish you and the team good luck in
implementing some of those enhancements
thanks david for diving into the details
of this incredible journey and
architecture with me well thank you for
the opportunity to
share our experience in nihilus
well we just saw how nihilus migrated to
gke pub sub and spanner to achieve the
performance scalability and security
goals while keeping the costs in check
if you want to learn more check out the
blog i've linked below and if you got
any topic ideas for upcoming customer
stories put them in the comments below
and i will find that use case and bring
it to you bye
you